Next up, let's talk about the world partition tools that are available to you.
So we have world partition and world partition is automatic data management and distance
based level streaming as we mentioned at the start.
So it's a system that provides a complete solution for large world management.
The world partition system works by storing your world in a single persistent level file
and then subdividing that space into a streamable grid like you can see here.
And then the streamable grid cells use the configuration that you set on the runtime grid.
So these cells are loaded and unloaded at runtime by the presence of the streaming source.
As we mentioned before, the streaming source is going to be the player here.
And in this way, Unreal Engine only loads the parts of the level that the player sees
and interacts with at a given time.
So it's really, really nice, powerful optimization tool here.
We've got level instance in here.
So level instances were originally created to replace Fortnite's foundations,
allowing multiple instances of a level to be used in the world partition level and the classic.
So we improve the overall level editing workflow experience here.
So what are the features?
So the features are nested in hierarchical level instances.
We've got edit in context, which always is the original level, not a pair instance or data edit support.
We can also have multiple instances within the same world.
We've got an embedded mode, which is the default mode, and that's content pushed to the persistent world partition grid.
And we've also got level streaming mode for non one file per actor levels.
So if you do want to make use of level streaming, you can do that.
But also, as we mentioned at the start, the one file per actor is a really great system for collaborative environments.
Data layers on the level instance actor is also a good feature, and it's pushed to the entire content.
So what are the use cases here?
So we may do points of interest, we may do houses, standalone gameplay setups.
And then also, when we're talking about a packed level actor, we generate a single optimized version for the render engine blueprint actor.
So it supports only static mesh components.
So this is a non destructive way.
So if we are looking at the packed level actor, the features outputs a packed level actor blueprint, which with only static mesh from the content.
We've got the feature that outputs a level that is linked to a packed level actor for non destructive editing.
And then also you can have multiple instances like any other actor within the same world.
And then the data layers are packed on the level actor only.
So really, really cool features there.
And then the use cases of the packed level actor might be static buildings in the city demo or very dense visual only setups with multiple instances of the same models.
So as we've been alluding to the one file per actor is a really powerful tool to use in your projects in previous versions of Unreal.
When you wanted to make changes to one or more actors inside a level, you needed to check out that entire level in source control, which meant multiple people couldn't work on it.
So it locked the team members out of that file until the work was complete.
It could then slow down the development process because only one person could work on that file.
So one file per actor reduces overlap between users by saving data for instances of actors in external files, removing the need to save the main level when making changes to its actors.
So one file per actor is enabled by default when using world partition.
And the use of one file per actor outside of world partition is currently considered experimental and is disabled by default.
So one file per actor feature is designed to be granular and can be used in two different ways.
So first way, after selecting the option, you'll be asked if you want to enable the feature for all the actors in the level.
Select yes to convert all the actors to one file per actor or no, which only enables it for the selected actor.
So you can either say yes, I want to convert all actors to one file per actor or no, I only want to use it on this one actor that I have selected.
So it's kind of opt in or opt in to everything per actor, which is a really cool tool there.
We also got data layers inside of Unreal Engine.
So data layers are a system within world partition used for organizing the actors into separate layers.
So the layers can be loaded and unloaded to organize your world.
So data layers serve as a replacement for previous layers found in older versions of Unreal.
And with data layers, gameplay elements and environment assets can be separated in the editor at runtime.
So if you're using data layers, what does that mean?
How can we separate an editor and at runtime?
So it means that artists can work on specific elements without interacting with gameplay triggers or objects.
Designers can dynamically load layers to design intriguing gameplay and elaborate level transitions at runtime.
This can be useful for gameplay purposes.
Keeping with the world partition system's goal of minimizing file overlap between users,
we can have data layers that reduce the need for users to check out important files such as world map file or actor files when making changes.
Each data layer has a display label and an internal unique identifier.
And then Unreal stores the information in a list of data layers in the world data layer file, which provides some of the benefits that I'm going to go into.
So three benefits here of world data layer is assigning data layers to an actor only affects the actor's file in world partition, which uses the one file per actor.
We can also rename a data layer to have it only affect the associated level.
So then there'd be no need to update any actors associated with that layer.
You can also delete the data layer, which only affects the world data layer file.
So actors previously associated with the data layer are automatically cleaned up with no need to modify or save the actor.
So data layers states can also be changed via blueprints.
Next, looking at the hierarchical level of detail, which is the HLOD.
This system uses HLOD layers to organize large amounts of static mesh actors to generate a single proxy mesh and material.
So this technique is used to visualize unloaded world partition grid cells to reduce the number of draw calls per frame.
And it also increases performance, especially when you have these large open worlds.
So you can create a HLOD layer by right clicking in the content browser and going to miscellaneous HLOD layer.
And then you can have various HLOD layers that are used throughout your entire project.
So the settings on the HLOD are instancing, merged mesh, simplified mesh and approximated mesh.
So with the instancing, which is the first option, the layer is composed of an instant static mesh.
So you might say ISM for instant static mesh and their components used with the lowest level of detail meshes.
So if you're using instancing, that's ideal for imposters, for example, trees ought to replicate the source actors geometry whilst dropping non-visual data.
Merged mesh, meshes included in this layer are merged to create a single mesh.
Simplified mesh, where mesh is included in that layer, are merged and the mesh is simplified for performance.
And then the approximated mesh is similar to simplified mesh, but it uses a newly developed algorithm that performs much better on complex scenes, which contains many instances on nano enabled static meshes.
So to see the changes, you'll need to go to the build menu at the top of your editor and select the build HLOD option.
And then the system will only build LODs that are needed to be rebuilt.
So this can be done from a command line as well, so that it can be run during nightly builds as well.
Looking at the virtual textures, and so virtual texturing is needed for the minimap generation, like we said at the start.
So while it's not required for open world tools to work, it does help and should be used whenever possible.
So Unreal Engine supports two virtual texturing methods.
We've got the runtime virtual texturing, which you'll sometimes see as RVT, runtime virtual texturing and streaming virtual texturing SVT.
So runtime virtual textures are used for procedurally generated content and heavy layered materials.
Supports larger texture resolutions.
The textual data cached in memory on demand.
Textual data is generated by the GPU at runtime and it's well suited for textual data that can be rendered on demand.
Such as procedural textures or composite layer materials.
So the streaming virtual textures are used for reducing texture memory overhead when using larger texture sizes for items like lightmaps.
So it supports larger texture resolutions.
Textual data is cached in memory on demand.
Textual data is cooked and loaded from disk and that's well suited.
So streaming virtual textures are well suited for textual data that takes time to generate, such as lightmaps or large detailed artist created textures.
So using virtual shadow maps, which you'll sometimes heard as referred to as VSMs, is a new shadow mapping method used to deliver consistent high resolution shadowing that works with film quality assets and large dynamically lit open world.
So VSMs are built to work seamlessly in Unreal Engine.
And we can use the Nanite virtualized geometry, the Lumen global illumination reflections and also world partition features with virtual shadows.
And lastly, we have Nanite. So Nanite is Unreal Engine 5's virtualized geometry system, which uses the new internal mesh format and rendering technology to render pixel scale detail and high object counts.
And it intelligently does work on only the detail that can be received and no more.
So only what the viewer can see, it'll work on that.
So Nanite's data format is highly compressed and supports fine grained streaming with automatic level of detail.
So Nanite should generally be enabled whenever possible.
So any static mesh that has it enabled will typically render faster and take up less memory and also disk space.